on today's show we're gonna be talking
about how to love somebody
when they emotionally beat themselves up
all the time
we're gonna be talking to a mom about
ownership and responsibility
and dealing with a teenager with anxiety
adhd
and a history of working with school
systems and we're going to talk about
our responsibility
when a teenager when a child cries out
for help
stay tuned
what is up i'm john and this is the dr
john deloney show
where we take your calls about your life
about the things that are going on in
your homes
and your schools and your marriages and
here's the deal
the goal of this show is to help you
rethink re-examine
reconsider your lives how you talk to
yourself how you talk to your kids how
you talk to those that you love
and how to honor those people that you
just can't stand
how to unhook the chains of those people
who have hurt you in the past
and how to how to take next steps for
the rest of your life
my goal is to take the mental health and
relationship challenges
the confusing and ever-changing science
those basic ways of living that have
been way over complicated
way over professionalized super
far removed from normal people like you
and me
and your neighbors and my goal is to
to bring it down speak common sense help
you get to tomorrow
and get to the next day and build a
future that you can be proud of
that you can be whole you can laugh a
lot and be a person of joy
all right and so on today's show we're
going to be talking about relationships
relational iq
your mental health we might even talk
about
elderly neighbors who see little kids
next door
and they go out of their way to say
hello even when it's weird even when
they think they've
they've separated from quote-unquote
that generation
and i think back to miss tarver
93 year old woman who made best friends
with my little son when he was five and
six and seven
and i just it it um it warms my heart on
this
cold morning here in nashville tennessee
and i i
i love it when people step out of their
comfort zone and say you know what i'm
gonna befriend you anyway
so we may be we're gonna be talking
about everything today so whatever's
going on in your heart in your mind your
universe i'm here to walk with you
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
and of course you can email me at ask
john ramseysolutions.com
let's ask john ramseysolutions.com
we've already got people on the phone so
let's go to joann
in seattle good morning joanne how are
we doing
i'm doing good how are you very good how
can i help this morning
my fiance is very competitive
he's competed on a professional level in
the past
and he has a very high expectation
and standard for who's going to be in
his life
and when he feels like he's failing at
that he gets
really upset and negative towards
himself and
i just want to know how i could be a
good
support system for him since we're going
to be getting married
like i want to be able to help him
through that not necessarily like
take over for him or anything but make
it a little bit less
of a issue when it those episodes come
up
what did he do professionally he was a
junior national mogul skier
a mogul skier so he's like he's a
gangster dude he like goes up and down
the big bad boys huh yeah he uh
even he used to do front flips
when they flipped and that was something
that they didn't do because it was too
dangerous
yep i'm going with a notebook i don't
like to i don't like to front flip into
a pool man by myself where no one will
even laugh at me when i belly flop
out man so so what do you love about
this dude
pretty much everything about him um he
was
he he's very generous for other people
he goes out of his way to do things for
other people
he just has always been helping so like
his parents have always
taught him to be like if something needs
to be done you see someone moving
something you go over there you offer to
help them move it
regardless if you're on your way to
somewhere that's what you do
and he's just he's very kind he's a
little bit more
um i want to say a little more
traditional that we no longer have in
our society i guess
he's just a he's a he's a an old soul
right he opens doors for you
he tips well he says thank you so
you mentioned two things that i couldn't
tell what you're struggling
with is it that he's got high
expectations of the people that he
allows into his life and so i'm going to
interpret that as he expects you to be
in great shape he expects you to eat
in a certain way he expects you to fill
in the blank or
you don't like him you don't like him
beating himself up
he's when he gets negative on himself
man he just spirals out and really
struggles
it's it's more the second one he he's
more than happy
to help when like i'm asking him to help
me
eat better or make sure that i get to
the gym those kinds of things he
he's more than happy to help with those
things but it's not
i have to or he you know he doesn't
mention you need to eat better
you need to go to the gym more or
anything like that but he's like
there to help with that so it's more he
just beats himself up really bad
give me an example of the last time he
just went to war with himself
um so he since mogul skiing
he kind of changed his competitiveness
into
the crossfit world
oh sweet he doesn't
does he does he have awesome sayings all
over your house like on chalkboards and
stuff
no he surprisingly doesn't oh good for
him
awesome he doesn't really tell people
that he crossfits unless they ask
um i heard a great joke the other day
here's what it was
uh an atheist a crossfitter a vegan
and a keto person walk into a bar how
did i know
in the the punchline is cause they all
wouldn't shut up about it
so that's awesome okay so he is the he
is a unicorn
he is a crossfitter who's a formal
profession a former professional athlete
who doesn't tell everybody about it you
may have found
the snowflake that that can complete
your soul right
so yeah so he he goes to a crossfit
workout he's struggling but
he he what so
recently we haven't been able to train
as hard or go to the gym as hard just
because of life
and he had a previous shoulder injury
from
mobile skiing and so when it comes up to
bother him in a workout and he can't
perform the way that he's used to or the
way that he wants to
he gets really upset and this last
conversation we had
he was um like i don't want to be just
another person walking through the world
like i want people to
see me and think i want to be like that
guy
he's like it's not necessarily for the
validation from other people
but i want to i want to matter to the
world and i want to do something
and he's and i'm like well you're also
going to school to be a nurse
you know you can't be a you know games
level crossfit athlete
and the nurse at the same exact time you
can work on both but not
you know because that's a lot to
spread out over how much time we have in
a day
and he says that he understands that and
so i tried to ask him like
oh well have you thought about things
you could do in the community to matter
like people can know your name without
you know really knowing you or without
you knowing about it and things like
that
and he just he just struggles he doesn't
know like
exactly what to do when he gets in those
situations sure
so um this is a common challenge of
folks who were
high school heroes who were
even mediocre college athletes around
the right crew
those who were great college athletes
those that were former professional
athletes
and i'll even i'll even extrapolate this
even further i think this is a broader
cultural illness with professional
athletes with
you know especially collegiate athletes
that takes up so much of your time and
so much of your head space
and you get so connected to those
teammates into that that
world i understand wholeheartedly that
that winds into your identity that
becomes a who you are that becomes your
tribe that becomes your gang i get that
but stepping back further this is a
little bit beyond that
and it was i heard i first remember
hearing this back when i was in college
when the movie fight club came out
and when brad pitt when tyler durden is
talking to this crew and he's telling
him
we were all told we were going to be
rock stars and movie stars
and we're all going to be rich we're all
going to be something important
and we're not and there's this idea
in our culture that if you aren't a
quote unquote influencer if you aren't
quote unquote
better than average if you're not able
to walk down the street and people look
at you and whisper about you
then you're nothing and you don't matter
the challenge for you joanne is you
can't fix
that what you can do is you can love him
the best way that you can
and what i'll tell you is it sounds like
he's a person a character
and it sounds like he was somebody who
was raised right and it sounded like
somebody who works really hard
and so there will come a season there
will come a moment
when he that hard work that ability
if it doesn't turn into self-loathing he
can turn that on himself
and really begin the mining process of
who am i
outside of being an athlete what is my
value outside of being recognized and
quote unquote better than
you guys at doing front flips while
going down a hill
right there will come a moment when he's
able to turn that on himself
and really go through an introspective
process it's usually pretty painful
it's usually uncomfortable but it
usually
it's a blessing for that person but it
can be really tough to love that person
i've been there i've worked through that
of course man like i say i wasn't a uh
down
downhill athlete but i lived for so many
years
wanting to be looked at when i walked
into a room i wanted people to turn
their head and be like oh there's that
you know what i mean and what what i'm
going to tell you i'm going to tell
everybody to listen to this that's a
hollow hollow way of living what you can
do joanne
as somebody who loves a guy like this
who's clearly a good person who's
clearly
exciting and fun and does great things
but has that
that untethered part of their soul which
again
all of us have it's some shape form or
fashion is you can sit them down and say
i don't care that you won some medals
i don't care that you
used to be able to go down a hill really
fast on a couple of sticks
i love you and you can show him that you
love him
all of the time you can when he starts
talking about hey i've got this pr you
could say i don't care about that how
are you feeling today
what's your what's your how's your heart
doing today let's go for a walk together
let's just hold hands
and you can begin to slowly move
his relationship with you to not
something special out there but
something special between the two of you
this is gonna be a frustrating thing a
hard thing to love somebody making that
transition
um it sounds like he's worth it it
sounds like he's awesome
you can also let him know man i'd love
to talk to him i'd love to hear directly
from him
why he beats himself up how he beats
himself up and man
i could maybe save him 15 years of his
of of
self-inflicted soul wounds um because
i've been there
i've walked through that awful
nonsensical treating myself like crap
and there's millions and millions of
people who have so
thanks for that call joanne love him
dearly let him know that you love him
not because
of the stuff he's done but the person
who he
is and i was gonna say guys but men and
women
people don't value you they shouldn't
value you
you shouldn't value you because of the
things you accomplish
you should be worthy of value you are
worthy of value because
you are you not because you're a
snowflake and special and kumbaya and
angels float down and
snow globe stuff comes but i mean this
in the most
basins you're a person you've got value
you've got dignity
i don't care how fast you were in high
school track i don't care if you were a
two-year starter on my jv football
program yeah
i don't care about any of that stuff let
that stuff go put that stuff down
oh i've got an idea joanne you know what
you should do you should have a funeral
with him
you should have a funeral for his skiing
career
i've been doing a lot of reading and
writing on grief recently
have a funeral for his skiing career
i want you to go have a process with him
i want you all to
write a letter about what it meant what
it means that it's
over now and i want you to have a
process where you put those
letters in a fire or you you frame them
and put them on the wall whatever
ceremony
you two you to have have a funeral
service
for skiing so we can put a period at the
end of it
and then i want you to have a process
for
what's tomorrow what's the future going
to look like what's it going to be like
for joanne and a former professional
athlete
to to get out of nursing school together
to think about getting married to have a
family who are you going to be what are
you going to build into these kids
and let him know that the past is the
past it's great but you love him for who
he is and where y'all are going
i like that idea and again thank you for
letting me think through this here while
i'm just sitting here
running in my head have a funeral for it
put a period at the end of it
and then he's going to have a morning a
time of mourning a time of grief
probably a time of lowness
and then he can start building from
there because he's a guy of character
and he knows how to work hard so that's
awesome thanks for the call julian
let's go to nora in washington dc nora
good morning how are we doing
good morning john can you hear me all
right i can hear you perfectly
what's going on well
first off thank you for taking the call
absolutely thanks for calling in
um and i wrote it down so i could be
very precise
son senior in high school diagnosed with
add
third and between third and fourth grade
also diagnosed with anxiety
has an iep has a therapist had all the
special education teachers
and some were good some were bad and
no matter what we did it still seems
like they're making him
feel like it's just sort of glossed over
his add
and so now that he's a senior in high
school he's you know
kind of miserable and i don't feel like
he's
learned the executive skill set that he
needs and
i actually started to resent it somewhat
but your broadcast where you had the um
the adult add and his wife
[Music]
really spoke to me and that's when i was
able to release that resentment so i'm
trying to help him now what can i do
awesome so walk me back to
your beautiful little boy at third grade
fourth grade
what what was going on in your heart and
mind that let you know
he's struggling well we were blessed
uh my husband is the son of educators
okay and my husband has some anxiety
issues as well so we could spot it
pretty easily in our
our oldest son and so we
on privately had testing done between
the two years
but we also what about what caused the
testing what was going on in your
in your son's life that made you think
he needs to be tested for something
oh um he was very sensitive
in third grade they think thinking that
he had something wrong with him they put
him in this class
with a with people who weren't being
looked after
if you know what i mean they had issues
but
for whatever the reason the family
wasn't available or whatever i don't
know
but it was he is like in kindergarten he
would cry
that was normal later on he would cry
and that wasn't normal or considered
normal and so he switched it to anger
so there was a a difficulty
being able to manage whatever stimuli
was in front of him and if he was very
frustrated
um and then my husband looked at it and
said we are pulling him out
we're going to send him over we're
getting into better school
and then also we had him tested and we
had um you know
we moved forward from there so what was
going on in your home environment during
that time
like when i think of anxiety i just it's
it's an alarm system
when i think of adhd it is just a
biological and neurological response
it's a natural response to chaos
what was going on in y'all's home and
this isn't an accusation this is just a
mining process we're just going for a
walk together in the woods what was
going on there that
that let this little boy not feel like
he could be heard or feel like he was
disconnected what was going on there
well there wasn't anything in particular
we were living in a town house
and and everything was reasonably okay
we were concerned for
him um because of this but i mean from
the day he was born he was always
sensitive
okay um and to be honest i don't know if
you want to go there but
we've i feel like he's an empath as well
i don't know if that makes it worse or
not but we can move on from there
but the environment i mean it was more
stimulated
because we were near a highway
but otherwise but you told me you told
me his dad was anxious
so yes and his dad deal with anxiety
he went to a therapist and was on
medication and and is still on
medication and still does the therapist
so what i'm what i'm trying to back out
is
less um please hear me here and everyone
listening to this
um i've i've met with folks who just
break down in tears when we have these
conversations
and it's not about accusations
it's it's about awareness right it's not
about blame it's about trying to
just say oh okay i see that um because
that's the only way we're gonna solve
the problem down the stream here
um so if you got a dad with anxiety how
does dad deal with
stress does he disconnect does he get
loud does he go for walks what does dad
do for
for stress management um
i would say that he disconnects okay
more than anything um
in the same room but that's yeah that's
and
that's the way i do it and i have found
over the years
that may be the most insidious way
because when somebody disappears out the
front door
you know there's a break you know
they're gone
when somebody's with you it's like um
it's like almost this ghosting
gaslighting
i'm with you but i'm completely
disconnected from you and it makes
people feel
crazy because they you're with them in
in body but you're not with them in
spirit how do you deal with stress and
frustration
how do you deal with anxiousness yeah
you
i'm still working on it how do you deal
with it
oh i i somewhat disconnect as well okay
so take me back to 15 years ago what was
going on in y'all's world where
something would come home your husband
would get frustrated or he would take
some medication he would sit like a
zombie
or a disconnected person who's with
everybody in the living room
and then you come in and things haven't
been done you're frustrated
what's your what's your internal
response or external response
well first off we i was at home
i was an at-home mother so
when dad would come in he would talk to
me
he would play he would play with kids he
would play with the dog
and then he would sort of check out you
know we would have dinner
sure um
[Music]
you know i i really want to answer your
questions but i'm not sure i
know the answers well that's oh and
again i'm just trying to
give myself um some some breadcrumbs to
follow here into the woods
so fast forward to me now you've got a
son how old is he
17. 17. so he's is he a senior now is he
a junior now
he's a senior okay so this is his last
year before he starts heading out so
what does anxiety look like for him now
what does adhd look like for him now
um you know you're talking about
checking out he uses a computer to check
out
okay and that's pretty much his only
thing
although he does do a little gardening
um in terms of adhd it's a lot of
anxiety
it's a lot of trying to figure out how
to do work without having a bunch of
people nag
him uh because to be honest that's what
the school system did they basically
just nagged him to get his work done
and i i feel like that's not really
teaching executive skills
how did you guys support him um
we did what we could i tried to learn
what i could but i
tried to rely on the school system
because i didn't want to get in you know
it's that catch-22 you want to help but
you also don't want to
enter you know get in the way of what
excuse me what the professionals should
be doing um
and but the and now that he's in high
school he has
um his special ed teacher and the guy is
really really nice
but he's not teaching any skill sets
that
my son really needs so so listen a lot
of
a lot of your response is super common
for folks with special needs kids
for for folks with young kids or for
older kids who
are they are just butting heads with or
they're just kind of at a loss
okay but every time i'm asking you a
question
you're pointing to somebody else as the
problem and so i want to get from you
is over the last 10 years over the last
five years over the last five months
how are you encouraging him to get his
work done how are you
reconnecting with him how are you
setting up situations where those alarms
are gonna come down
because here's the deal anxiety adhd
those are contexts they're not an excuse
you still got to get your work done
sure right you still got to go do those
things
and blaming all these external systems
while it's real
it's hard and it's annoying some schools
are super equipped
some teachers are extraordinary
some maybe aren't nobody can replace the
mom and dad in this situation
and so what your school system isn't
going to solve this problem at age 17
the healing is going to come from you
but it's got to start with you being
reflective
saying what am i bringing to this
situation because it's my
son so i only can talk to you joe and
you're the only one on the phone with me
when when your son is struggling when he
is like having mythical thinking about
time
or he is real frustrated because he's
procrastinating again or he can't find
his hat
again or his keys are missing again how
do you
participate in what happens next
um for the last couple of years i think
it's been difficult to be patient
but at the same time i am his sounding
board i am the one he comes to
i do work with him as best i can i also
work with the school system
to see i was writing emails going give
me advice
tell me what to do you know talk to the
administration
who anybody i could talk to to get
more insight into what to do now the
these two years were the hardest it
turns out that
the my son the freshman year in the
sophomore year
nick my son was doing much better um
really grasping really enjoying school
and school was done
at school and then home was home
and then the way they have it set up
here the the
junior year for whatever the reason is
meant to be the hardest
and so it really taxed all of his
abilities
and we got tutors and we got you know
whatever we needed
but it was very hard for him and then of
course kovit came in and
and it was everything turned upside down
but but listen
heart is a good thing heart is a great
thing it can be
challenging and some schools can be
failure factories
but hard is not a bad thing taking a kid
who is able to skate through his
freshman and sophomore year
and then runs up against the brick wall
that is your junior year that's pre-cal
that's all that
you know it's getting into some really
complex things it's it's
getting past the social studies stories
and now we're getting to the
the depth that's good stuff
and when a kid runs up against
hard and we're in a system where it's
like man the school is not helping
enough
or we've got to fill in the blank xyz
we've got to get this expert and that
expert
walk me through what is it that makes
you uncomfortable about your kid
struggling right now
because he should be he's a senior in
high school i want that to be hard
because then next year is going to be
college and that's going to be real hard
it's living with it it's making sure
that he has
what he needs um he doesn't want us to
do things it's that that age
where he doesn't want us to okay you're
on you're on it now joey and you're on
it okay
listen my name is oh no
i'm so sorry it's okay okay we'll go
back i keep going joanna
um all right so you're on it nora you're
on it so here's the thing
you are uncomfortable with how he's
struggling how is he doing
well he doesn't like it either obviously
of course he doesn't he's not supposed
to
but how is he doing i'm not sure
um we are about to approach midterms
and he doesn't he's not telling us
anything you know i i ask him so i ask
him broader questions like okay
are you getting things done is you know
is there anything i need to be concerned
with
is there anything you need you know help
with or you know and so forth like that
i ask those kinds of questions
so that they're broader so it's a little
bit easier for him to answer
without getting into the weeds because
he doesn't want to tell me the weeds
okay so
here's the deal nor he doesn't get a
choice
and you don't get a choice okay
he doesn't get a choice you don't get a
choice he's your kid and he's at home
hard is good for kids it's good for them
and when parents rush in to try to swoop
and save them
it undermines their efficacy it
undermines
their ability to think about how good
they're going to be at something
it undermines their ability to fail and
realize that's not the end of the world
it sounds like you're the one in this
discomfort gap
you're the one that doesn't like to see
your kids struggling with
and he's stro and he's since he was
little since he came out
of the womb you guys have labeled him as
sensitive
as needing a little extra help as
somebody who needs a diagnosis as
somebody who needs
he's probably going to need he cries a
lot he's a little bit more sensitive
and instead of owning that relationally
it sounds like there's just been this
gap where it's that's a problem that's a
thing we've got to fix we got to get
special people here we got to do special
things here
and now he's 17 and you still are
feeling this
weight on your heart in your mind and so
asking generalized questions to a kid
that's had
um learning challenges asking
broad questions no man you've got to get
in
the middle of it nora you've got to take
him out
forget about the assignments forget all
that stuff you got to take him out and
say
how are you doing i am your mom i am
forcing you to talk to me
you have to be in my life you have to be
in my heart you've got to let me know
what's going on in your heart
and i'm going to talk to you and so if
we're just going to go for a walk every
night
great i'm going to make you hold my hand
because i am your freaking mom and moms
all across the country are laughing at
me right now
and i do not care you're going to tell
your son you got to hold my hand because
i'm your mom and you have to
my mom is 70 years old and when i see
her she says
you have to hug me and i'm going to
anyway but she just gets to say that
because i'm her
kid i'm her son so a 17 year old doesn't
get vague
questions a 17 year old that you're
worried about
you're worried about how they're
processing things you're worried about
their anxiety their disconnection
they don't get generalized questions
they get specific show me your work
today
and is it a pain oh my gosh yes having
kids is hard
is it a struggle yes but what's going to
happen is
you're going to not sen you're gonna
you're gonna spend a semester
what's gonna happen is you're gonna
spend a semester saying how are things
going
you got your assignments done and your
kid's gonna go yeah got it
i'm good and then you're just gonna go
back to the computer and the next day
how's everything going good fine and
then you're going to keep going they're
going to keep going
and then you're going to get to midterms
and they're going to have four zeros
and two c's and what you're going to do
is get mad and you're going to call the
school
and you're going to say nobody called me
nobody did this nobody
it's your responsibility but it starts
not with the assignments it starts not
with the diagnosis
it starts not with the other people
or challenges it starts not with my kids
broken
it starts with hey good boy good morning
how are you
hey good boy i love you come over here
and give me a hug before the day even
starts
it starts with hey what's today going to
look like what's one awesome thing
you're going to think about before you
leave
it starts with have you got your
homework done yet because we got our
nightly walk and we do not miss nightly
walk time
it starts with if you don't get off that
computer i'm going to throw it off the
roof
and we're going to watch it smash into a
million pieces because my relationship
with you
is more important than you plugging into
some dumb box
and i know this is hard i was an 80d kid
i was an anxious kid i still struggle
with anxiety now
it's a conscious constant battle that i
gotta stay in front of
i've worked with countless college
students
high school students struggle with add
anxiety
and it usually starts
from chaos in the home disconnection in
the home
moms and dads who are trying just to
keep things plugged in this isn't a
blame conversation this is
hard
parents who are just trying to get the
bills paid parents who are just trying
to get to tomorrow they're dealing with
their own junk that their parents gave
to them and that their parents gave to
them
or that their community gave to them or
their country gave to them however that
works
but when you start at age four telling a
kid that hey you may be broken
you're probably need some special stuff
they're gonna live into that and if you
do have a kid with special needs
stay on top of those teachers stay on
top of those
um those professionals who live in those
worlds
and never ever ever think to yourself
well i don't want to get involved get
involved
get involved one of the
the terms i hate the most is the term
helicopter parent
i hate it i hate it i hate it and here's
why your kid is the most precious thing
on planet earth to you
it does not ever
occur to me to not get involved with my
kids ever
i just i worked at colleges for years i
loved it when parents called that meant
that they cared about their kid
but moms and dads
brothers and sisters
you gotta let your kids fail too you
gotta let them experience consequences
too there's a difference between saying
hey i'm worried about my son are they
okay
and this is your fault
this is your fault nora i know you love
your boy i want you to back out
i want you to back way out 30 000 feet
you got a year left with him or now
you're down to nine months before he
goes to college
or who knows how long cove is going to
last maybe he's going to live at home
for the next few years
for the next 30 days i want you to tell
him you talked to some knucklehead on
the radio
who said every morning we have to start
the morning with a hug
every morning we have to start with me
looking you in the eyes and telling you
i love you and i'm so glad you're my son
every morning you start with i'm so glad
that people in the world were made to
feel like you do
every morning you talk about hey what's
today's plan i want you to make a list
with him this is going to be for 30 days
you're going to be annoyed by this by
the end of it make a plan for today
when he gets home at the end of that day
i want you to say what's one awesome
thought you had today
at the end of the day i want you to hug
him before you start talking to him
about school work
at the end of the day i want you to say
what assignments do you have today that
you need to get done
how can i help you i want to see them
before you're done
and before you get on the computer we go
on for our walks
and that means we don't get on the
computer tonight that means we don't get
on the computer tonight
we're going to go out and garden
together we're going to go out and kick
the soccer ball i'm going to go and do
some stuff together
and i want you to try to put the
assignments down
the well what about what i want you to
try connecting
try connecting first
just try for 15 years you've tried other
things try this
and that's not a matter of coming in and
playing with the dog and saying i want
you to connect connect
connect and nora i want to to honor you
for being a mom that still cares about
her kid who still loves her kid he's
still trying to figure it out he's not
giving up on their 17 year old and their
18 year old
millions of parents do thank you for
being a parent that cares
take full full ownership of your boy
and start with connecting he's worth it
all right let's go to david in
austin texas david what's up brother how
are we doing
hey john i appreciate your work thank
you good man i appreciate you giving me
a call how can i help
so yeah my niece has been um saying
a lot of suicidal thoughts on her social
media and
talking to her closest cousins about it
um me and my wife are currently on
military orders in texas
and my niece lives in new jersey i just
i just want to know what can we do
from from here um so when you say
suicidal messages what's what's she
posting what's she putting up
so she has been posting um my wife found
her account on tick tock and she's been
posting things about
um her past with her bad relationship
with her father
um what do you mean by bad uh
so she two years ago
recently found out from her school that
from her father's side her
father's younger brother was sexually
assaulting her
for a few years and she recently came
out and
and confessed who was a school counselor
in
two years ago since then the father took
the brother's side and
pretty much is out of the picture of her
life is that brother in jail
um i think they're the case is pending
yes
well good i hope he goes to prison all
right so
um and so now she's living in the
aftermath what was dad's response
afterwards what was mom's response
afterwards
her parents so her her dad to one
when they found out was uh he didn't
believe her
um the mom believed her and
you know called the cops and and when
they went to therapy and stuff like that
but
the mom is not i think her mom
has had some troubles too as well um has
a lot of other issues
and things like that so so forget their
moms and dad's personal issues how did
they deal with this young lady
so dad said i don't believe you didn't
happen until finally
he came around and believed that it did
uh no he
he didn't really either he didn't
believe that it did he just kind of
he's he's not he's he's kind of a
one of those guys who are pretty much
like uh into drugs
and um running around in the streets and
things like that
he's never been involved he's a burnout
okay yeah yeah
great great great father there okay so
you have this young lady how old is she
she's 13. you have a 13 year old on
tick-tock and social media what is she
saying
so um the latest thing i saw was uh
her saying how sad she is how her mother
doesn't reach out to her talk to her
how when she went to counseling with the
state and all that
that they were just making her relive
what happened
they didn't seem like they even cared
about her um so it discourages is
discouraging her from trying to
get help and then the latest thing
recently now is
um she's asking what are some painless
ways
that she can um kill herself i guess
yeah um not i guess when a 13 year old
is asking for
painless ways that's that's that's the
definition of crying for help
yes and that's what's really concerning
yeah you should be super concerned
um when a dad doesn't believe his
daughter
when a mom doesn't comfort her daughter
when the whatever mental health
professional wasn't able to connect
there
yeah that's a recipe for disaster
and so what this young girl is doing is
using the only tools 13 year olds have
these days which is social media
right or wrong and she is screaming out
to the world somebody help
me and so who have you called
so my wife her is her
her is related to her mother um
we she does she doesn't have a great
relationship with her sister because uh
her sister
feels like my wife is always telling her
how
oh bickering at her or saying uh
trying to control her or something so
hold on hold on hold on i don't
i i don't care if
i don't care anything about anybody's
relationships with anybody
what i'm asking you brother is who have
you called
so my wife called
um the only person that her sister
listens to
and she sat down and talked with her
sister and
she said she was going to get help with
her she said she was going to help her
uh get accounts and things like that but
um the way her sister is she's not one
to really follow through with it and
that's
where i feel really uneasy about it okay
good so
she will but she never follows you know
she won't right so
um here's the famous saying not by your
hand but in your lap
and this isn't something that you ask
for but you're a caring compassionate
guy
you clearly are about serving people
beyond yourself that's why you're in the
service while your wife in the service
you guys are are givers and servers and
so i want to free you i want to free
every listener from any qualm any like
i don't know what to do next if you are
walking down the street and you see a
teenager
crying out for help if you have a third
cousin second removed
and their biological mom is in jail and
their biological dad was mean one time
at christmas and y'all haven't talked
for a few years
or in a messy situation like the one
you're in
i don't care i don't care i don't care
all that nonsense peels away brother and
you've got a
13 year old girl yelling in the only way
she knows how
saying help me please
mom doesn't count mom is doesn't work
she doesn't
do anything mom is not helpful she's not
going to follow through
daughter wouldn't be in this situation
daughter wouldn't be crying out for help
in these ways if mom was responding in
the right way
you know what that's not fair to even
say i'm not going to say that
that's not fair that happens um if mom
was present
there would be different responses going
on here okay i understand
so here's the deal you call 9-1-1
you call local school you call the local
child protective services
you call everybody you can get their
number
yes okay and i don't care about the
relationship violation
i don't care if your wife's sister is
going to be
mad i don't care there's a 13 year old
good girl saying help me please
yeah you know what i mean now i want to
tell you this one story okay i worked in
crisis for years this is what i did i
showed up to suicide scenes i showed up
to
um shootings and car wrecks and i i
showed up to all kinds of different
situations and i also worked with young
people
and college students for years and years
and i remember a situation where
a couple of people all at the same time
told me they were worried about a
college student
and i couldn't get a hold of him until
finally the
the young person texted me and said i
want you to know that you've been
awesome
and something along the lines of i'll
see you on the other side or
take care something that made me it
wasn't a direct suicide threat but it
made me uncomfortable
so i did something weird that i don't
normally do i got in my car and just
drove to their house
this is an adult student the student was
25 or so as an adult student i drove to
their house knocked on the door and
their roommate was inside
the roommate said oh they're just
sleeping i said i want to see him with
my own eyes
so we went in their room they were
asleep the room looked real not good man
there was nothing on the walls there was
a couple of trash sacks it was just a
mattress on the floor there was a bottle
of pills by the bed
and there was a gun in the room and i
knew the room didn't look good
and i leaned down to talk to the student
they were snoring
in a really deep way and i leaned really
close
and i yelled as loud as i could nothing
yelled again nothing
and i just said man what like they're
clearly asleep right now
there's the bottle's still full of pills
you know i
they're in texas they're allowed to have
guns right i mean the math i was running
through my head for some strange reason
and i've done this
over and over and over again
i couldn't make this one add up so i
called a friend of mine
and you talk about providential i called
my friend who was another crisis
responder
and she happened to be at lunch with the
number one
college crisis counselor on the planet
brian van brunt
they're having lunch together and i'm
walking her through here here's what i'm
looking at
and brian yells at the table i heard him
through the phone
what are you doing call 9-1-1 and i went
oh my gosh call 9-1-1 and i had gotten
so deep into the relationship part
the roommate was saying no man he just
sleeps really heavy man he snores like
crazy all the time he's fine he's just
sleeping
turns out he was in the middle of a
suicide attempt
turns out he was had been crying out for
help
and i was somebody who does this for a
living and i was sitting right there and
i let all the other variables cloud
the one central judgment which was i
need to get this kid some help right now
and so i want to tell you that to tell
you this i'm not judging you i'm not
blaming you i'm not mad at you
but at the end of this phone call one
somebody from my team is going to make a
call
because that's what we do yeah at the
end of this phone call
you need to get with your wife and you
all rally up and before this
day is over probably before you have
lunch you got to start making some calls
to make sure this young girl's got some
adults in her area looking after her
because the adults who've been assigned
to her by god aren't showing up
and i want you to know i know that
there's a lot of relationship dynamics i
know there's a lot of this is in that
and so i want to help you the same way
brian and my friend helped me
cut through all that stuff you got a 13
year old girl saying please help me
and you need to get on the phone and
make those calls okay
sounds good yeah is that fair i
understand
completely yes and listen david i want
to commend you for being an uncle that
cares
i want to commend you for being a person
who loves his wife
and who sees something that's not right
and says i've got to get involved no
matter what
i've got to get involved no matter what
i just don't know the right thing to do
everybody listening to this here's the
right way to do it
you run out in the street with a pot and
a pan and you start banging them
together saying hey listen listen
somebody needs help
that's what you do and i hear people ask
like well what's my legal responsibility
what's my obligation
here's the deal when we start letting
the state or we start letting the
federal government define our baseline
for how we're going to treat one another
we're in a bad mess
churches schools workplaces
friends when our first thought is what
do i have to do
to care for somebody god help us man
god help us get involved
especially when it's a child
especially when it's a child who
suffered sexual abuse at the hands of
her brother
her dad turned his back on her and mom's
not showing up
get involved
brother david i am grateful for you man
i'm grateful for everybody out there
there are people out there right now who
have been thinking for a while should i
make that call
i i don't want to get involved i i would
much
much rather make a call much rather make
a call and have someone be like dude
what's the matter with you i'm
fine i'd much rather that call
than the one that you don't make and
then you find out hey
i hate to break it to you but so and so
took their life
so and so is in an institution now make
the call
so yeah man heavy show today all right
so as we're wrapping up today's show
i've been digging through the spotifys
i've been digging through the internets
trying to find
the greatest rap song of all time i've
landed on it chance the rapper
from his 2016 coloring book record the
song is blessings
and chance writes i'm at war with my
wrongs
i'm writing four different songs i never
forced you to forfeit it i'm a force to
be reconciled
they want four-minute songs you need a
four-hour praise dance performed
every morning i'm feeling shortness of
breath so nico grab you a horn hit
jericho with a buzzer beater to end a
quarter watch a brick and mortar fall
like
dripping water there are obstacles in
life
many many trials and tribulations that
come up but you got to realize and know
that
every jericho walls must fall fall
jericho fall
i'm going to praise him till i'm gone
this
is the dr john dolone show